600 pañuelos para los 600.000 muertos
vinculados al cove' 19
y
estos 600 pañuelos representan el dolor
de las pérdidas porque 600.000
brasileños han perdido la vida durante
la pandemia somos el segundo país del
mundo en número absoluto de muertos
durante casi seis meses una comisión
parlamentaria de investigación de la
pandemia ha escuchado a los testigos las
audiencias a menudo tormentosa se
retransmitieron en directo por
televisión el informe de mil páginas
acusa directamente al presidente ya ir
bolsonaro
el presidente publicitó medicamentos que
no estaban científicamente aprobados el
presidente hizo campaña a favor de la
cloroquina estuvo en contra de los
tapabocas el presidente estuvo a favor
de los mítines y estuvo en contra de
quedarse en casa
psíquicas
por su parte bolsonaro se negó a ser
entrevistado por la comisión de
investigación a pesar de haber estado
infectado por kobe y 19 sigue negando la
gravedad de la enfermedad desde el
inicio de la pandemia ha multiplicado
sus salidas polémicas sin tapabocas o
dando la mano en el momento álgido de
los contagios
hace unos días consideraba innecesario
vacunarse
porque necesito un pasaporte de
vacunación quería ver el partido del
santo si me dicen que tengo que vacunar
me porque tengo más anticuerpos que los
que han sido vacunados por la comisión
de investigación parlamentaria ha
presentado nada menos que 11 cargos
contra el presidente incluyendo el
homicidio por omisión e incluso crímenes
contra la humanidad los funcionarios no
tienen poder para procesar directamente
pero las mil páginas del informe se
enviarán a los organismos competentes
como el fiscal quien decidirá si seguir
con el proceso